what's your top three minorities that
you hate wait wait wait
here we are well i was gonna say
i was gonna say let's skip it until
michael hit the drum roll i mean you
can't really
all right
you guys think we should find out and
then edit it out if it's bad later
we gotta start at three though
but you can't say what you can't go on
the internet and say what happened if
you [ __ ] if we edit it out deal
or else we won't do it
all right
here we are hans kim's three least
favorite
minority groups everybody this is an
asian man during asian heritage month
we checked the rule book it's allowed
his girlfriend is a vegan without a
credit card so for you liberals out
there
you might be taking food if that's what
they call it away from a vegan with no
credit card
by trying to cancel hans but he's
uncancelable these are his top three
least favorite minority groups
starting with number three
sri lankans
[Music]
the crowd goes wild everybody feels like
it's safe to laugh now
we were really we were really concerned
you might just drop the n-word right
from the top there
right from the number three position sri
lanka is just happy to get recognized
all right here we are back to the show
the number two least favorite group of
immigrants to hans kim native americans
whoa
whoa
he's set us up all nice guys sri lankan
not gonna be that big of a deal
small island
now you go straight to the native people
of our very own land
they're poor and dirty
[Laughter]
wow
wow
wow
wow
oh my god
oh yes
oh yes
oh my god
chaos all right
believe it or not
there's one to go everybody
believe it or not raven you think the
gift cannot possibly give any more we
find out that the number one
least favorite minority group according
to hans kim is the blacks
[Music]
congratulations you guys congratulations
john dee's through a water bottle adam
he's up on the stool
an incredible standoff is
may versus february
[Laughter]
oh i activated the backlights that's a
big deal
[Music]